parmi les sorties dans les salles cette
semaine un film tout en finesse sur la
chine de l'époque de la révolution
culturelle des étudiants envoyés aux
champs pour être rééduqués par des
campagnards eux-mêmes analphabètes deux
jeunes gens vont parvenir à séduire une
jeune fille qu'ils vont initier à des
libertés à la liberté en lui apprenant à
lire les oeuvres de balzac balzac et la
petite tailleuse chinoise c'est le titre
de ce film my logement patrick ouart la
chine au début des années 70 vous
préviens mahon notre président vous
envoie là pour que vous soyez rééduquer
pas pour un bunker actionnaires dans les
montagnes des paysans accueille de
jeunes intellectuels la politique de mao
mettre ces jeunes bourgeois au contact
avec la dure réalité de la vie
c'est son histoire que d'haïti tuer
raconte ici raconte moi une histoire
sa rencontre avec une jeune fille
analphabète à qu'il va ouvrir le monde
grâce à balzac
quand j'ai grandi que je suis lire
révolution culturelle était là on avait
brûlé les vivres se connaît un raid
hippique y en a un tas de livres des
sentiers présent trop révolutionnaire
c'est eux qui devaient nous rééduquer
ces noms mission tous il prend ça très
sérieux mais c'est pour eux c'est très
difficile
éduqué comme on savait pas lire c'est
très difficile et tue quelqu'un qui sait
dire c'est là de toute tenue assez
absurde ce machin un jouet pour les
gosses de ces chiens de bourgeois brûle
ici pas de reconstitution historique
juste la vie pas tous les jours facile
de ces adolescentes les émotions et la
découverte de l'amour
bourgois cette fille qui a aimé par
isaac
mais pourquoi elle a choisi ces deux là
ça c'est un mystère du pot ce cas elle a
adoré cette ambiance de société dans
lequel des hommes s'étaient brouillés
pour plaire aux fans
des années plus tard d'haïti jay a revu
sa petite tailleuse chinoise elle n'a
pas pu lire son livre car il n'est pas
traduit en chinois lui curieusement il a
gardé une certaine nostalgie de cette
époque il dit que c'est sa jeunesse puis
de l'occident on ne retiendra le
romantisme